hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the right
hostile created by Mark are ok now this
is a game made by the same guy that made
the rake returned to asylum using the
FPS creator engine thingy which is the
same one that's used to make the
Slenderman shadow maps the rake
ha hmm ok still got the same flashlight
dookey mechanic oh hello
doors alright so the idea is generally
the same as before I think for the most
part anyway um you're wandering through
a hostile looking for something I didn't
get an objective I definitely didn't get
an objective this time which is one of
my criticisms in the last one I didn't
really have a clear objective but it
turns out in that when I did I just
didn't listen to it like I usually do
it's really dark like I mean it's darker
than usual I mean I got a flashlight
here but I think they kind of brought it
down
oh no no no no no no no no no aah damn
it mother
kya Gama are you doing a [__] out
aah looking at you good aah aah I should
I should have known something like I was
gonna happen I mean it was a room with a
dead end in it yeah okay that is el rake
Oh otherwise known as the rake oh yeah
mark you so funny
ha ha okay anyway so that was obviously
a dead end in a waste of my time
ah I get the feeling this thing's trying
to kill me yeah maybe I'm not sure some
something not right for anything behind
this desk I keep forgetting that I can
sprint so let's start doing that I don't
think there's a limit on the spread this
game huh a thing well that thing was a
great use of the shadows to just get its
eyes to pop out from the darkness oh not
a good ha ha ha
what why why did I die maybe I should
have known that it was going to be
another dead end room isn't it sorry
I've been getting a car yeah mmm see how
many weird faces mark Claire Ganesh yeah
yeah I do this valley little bit this
isn't a giftable moment I don't know
what is ah I'm done now okay rude jerk
okay so um yeah I was mr. rake guy I'm
guessing I stopped in the doorway
instead of moving forward that's what
got me excuse me I am getting a bit of a
cough which is bad because I'm gonna be
live-streaming this weekend so hopefully
that will not get too bad I'll get
myself a supply of cough drops and I'll
be good
oh hello mr. trash can barrels oh look
physics Hey
physics yeah okay so I'm still not
exactly sure what my objective is
besides exploration but I'll do my best
here to try to figure it out oh look
another dead-end remover
seriously what is it deal what am I
supposed to do I hate not having a clear
objective
mr. rake man what's the dealio mr. Reich
my own okay wait I might was that the
only way down
am I here am i running out of room to
run did I come from this way I can't I
don't even know anymore I don't even
know anymore
well that's different Han wheeled down
here hello hello anybody home
my name is markiplier oh not again ha ha
ha ha ha
my goodness didn't expect you to pop up
in front of me guy hey what's with Jimmy
oh hey hi [__] ow
yeah sure you anyway no nice you you're
eggy oh ok
gone now good to you didn't want to mess
with me oh look I'm a serious table in
the middle of the room how suspicious oh
look another table
I know bad things are just getting
weirder and weirder
ah God Ellen it's a dirt and the dirt
earned nothing special no items no cell
phone
mr. Rico help doesn't look like anything
it don't look like nursin I better get
the [__] out of here why am I talking
like t'rar / Oh No oh ha ha ha aah oh my
lord okay so did you like turn your
camera he disappears get him out of your
field of view oh man
so if I just start walking like this
there's no possible way he could beat me
I'm under duckbill with my technic Wow
bring it on Rick man you know whatever
what billiard tables with chairs hot
stuff strange broken boxes random desks
I think that maker this mad was just
trying to fill the rooms with random
crap ah why Wow what
I can't hide me buzz
what is the deal what is the deal what
is it going on what is the deal huh
was that just a random thing just to
give me the heebie-jeebies well good job
you only you always scared my audience
here ha ha you're also GERD I saw the
looks on your faces
ha ha ha don't even try to Johnny to try
to fake you were all terrified don't go
this way I think I went this way yeah
this was a dead end
all right lovely well this has been fun
and all I think I'm gonna go kill myself
dad go this way again I keep at you I
went this way this way came I'm gonna go
left here cuz [__] all I can't even
remember which way I came from cuz his
map is convoluted and strange no clear
direction every room looks the same I'm
surprised I managed to keep oh that's a
box yeah right to keep with it as long
as I could yeah I think I swear the
maker of this map just made a bunch of
rooms filled them with crap that has no
point to the setting like a billion
billiard tables cuz those are in hostels
ha ha ha Oh got you ha ha ha beat you
beat you patented technique Kramer
markiplier special break elimination
technique puh-pow the full file of your
let's call you called a flip-flop
trademark trademark whenever you
trademark something you gotta do this ok
so the full ow is now officially a
markiplier tactic and no one can beat it
I still don't know what the point of
this is I mean besides a huge what
what's up
who's that that toilet besides a few
jump scares
and uh a creepy atmosphere
ah Oh what the hell ha ha good you got
the double foie goddamn let me go the
bathroom in peace man
huh wait I can go bug I'm gonna bug
again yeah
damn oh hi
flip ow for foul oh it's apparently the
flip flower technique has a limited
range well now there's been nice being
in the bathroom and all blue you still
there buddy
how's gone friend flip out still didn't
work on you hey are you gonna regret
this
uh-oh I think this guy's for serious now
hello
did did defy foul what Oh were you
moving Wow what's going on foot file
you're twitching coming closer oh really
oh you think you're gonna step bigger
gonna mess me huh huh wah wah
come closer buddy oh you gonna give me a
heart huh
I think he's gonna give me a hug okay I
don't know what to do about this
Oh what that are you creeping along
opportunity I'm just looking over here
no dude what was that green light red
light green light red light green light
red light red red light red light I'm
going around screw you whoo you you
don't play fair all it is not the way I
want to go okay come here come here
thank you uh-huh hide around a corner
what if I go around you ugly
you should be were you protecting
clothing hmm maybe your secret diary
journal oh yeah I'd like green light red
light feel it
red light green light red brick okay
is there something over here that you
don't want me to see buddy
yeah tri-dot that's what I thought wait
oh this is nothing
well this is nothing boo oh God oh you
kill me how ah what ah all right so that
has been the rake Hostel yep that's the
in yeah yeah I know well I mean I didn't
see a clear point of the game and I had
no objectives I didn't even see a way to
get out of the exit so I have no idea
what was going on there so thank you all
so much for watching and always I will
see you
ah Superion oh we're gonna do this [__]